[Musik]
und jetzt das heute journal mit Heinz
Wolf und Marietta Slomka guten Abend
einen schlechteren Zeitpunkt hätte es
für Joe bidens Besuch kaum geben können
eine schwierige Mission war das ja eh
schon dass aber ausgerechnet am Vorabend
seiner Anreise die Lage derart eskaliert
und arabische Regenten vereinbarte
Termine mit ihm Absagen noch bevor er
ins Flugzeug nach telaviv steigt das ist
sicher nicht das was ich das Weiße Haus
vorgestellt hatte wie es zu der in jeder
Hinsicht fatalen Explosion an dem
Krankenhaus in Gaza kam steht in Frage
die israelische Armee hat inzwischen
eine ganze Reihe Dokumente vorgelegt um
zu belegen dass dort keine iselische
Rakete eingeschlagen ist doch für den
Sturm der Entrüstung der mit den Bildern
aus Gaza entfacht wurde kam das zu spät
l WP
berichtet der Parkplatz am achli
Krankenhaus in Gaza statt heute früh bei
einem Raketeneinschlag sollen hier
letzte Nacht 471 Menschen ums Leben
gekommen sein sagt die Hamas und
beschuldigt Israel das Krankenhaus
vorsätzlich angegriffen zu haben die
Ärzte immer noch unter
es gab keinerlei Warnung zum Zeitpunkt
der Explosion waren etwa 3000 Menschen
im Krankenhaus die dort Schutz
suchten ein Inferno so berichten
Augenzeugen das Grauen des Krieges
verbreitet sich im Netz und auf den
Nachrichtenkanälen in Windeseile Israel
bestreitet das Krankenhaus angegriffen
zu
haben das war der palästinensische
islamische dihad der die Raketen auf
Israel abgeschossen hat eineel
es sei so die Armee kein Bombentrichter
erkennbar die Explosion traf den
Parkplatz nicht das Gebäude so die Armee
präsentiert wird auch ein abgehörtes
Telefonat zwischen Mitgliedern der
Terrorgruppe und ein Video das den
Ablauf der Ereignisse zeigen soll die
Rakete startete demnach in Gaza zerbrach
kurz darauf in der Luft der intakte
Sprengkopf viel zu Boden und explodierte
im
Krankenhaus für US-Präsident Biden zum
krisenbesuch in is ein massiver
Rückschlag im Bemühen um eine Lösung des
Konflikts in vorsichtigen Worten
unterstützte er die israelische
Position ich war entsetzt und betroffen
von dem Verlust von Leben gestern in dem
Krankenhaus nachdem was wir wissen
scheint es eine fehlgeleitete Rakete von
Terroristen in Gaza gewesen zu
sein doch er weiß dass die Menschen in
der arabischen Welt längst ein anderes
Urteil gefällt haben Aufruhr herrschte
heute von Beirut bis ramala von bis ins
türkische Istanbul die Volksseele kocht
diplomatische Vertretungen Israels und
der USA wurden angegriffen 100000ende
ließen ihrer Wut freien Lauf ihrem Hass
auf Israel ein voller Erfolg für die
hamasterroristen ihr Kalkül geht
auf ich rufe alle Menschen der
arabischen und islamischen Nationen auf
dieses Massaker zu verurteilen diese
Brutalität diese Verbrechen geht auf die
Straße um den Feind zu
stoppen der Konflikt spitzt sich weiter
zu immerhin gab es am Abend eine gute
Nachricht für die Menschen in Gaza
israel will jetzt Hilfslieferungen aus
Ägypten
zulassen diesen akuten Sturm jetzt
wieder einzufangen irgendwie ist nun
auch noch Ziel aller diplomatischen
Bemühungen dabei waren die
Herausforderungen auch ohne das
krankenhausereignis schon groß genug der
US-Präsident wollte mit seinem Besuch
Israel Solidarität zeigen es zugleich
zur Mäßigung anhalten und eine klare
Warnung Richtung Teran senden wagt es
nicht in diesen Krieg direkt
einzusteigen für all das braucht es
Abstimmung mit den anderen Playern in
dieser Region und das ist jetzt noch
schwieriger geworden goline atai
berichtet Ankunft in einem Land im Krieg
a Stunden wird Joe Biden hier verbringen
die Liebe zu Israel sei in seiner
politischen und emotionalen DNA
verankert sagen Beobachter aber es ist
heute alles andere als leicht einerseits
geht es um Unterstützung für Israel
andererseits darum eine regionale
Eskalation zu
verhindern ich will dem israelischen
Volk sagen euer Mut euer Einsatz eure
Tapferkeit ist bewundernswert ich bin
stolz hier zu
sein er trifft die Großmutter Rachel
eDRi die 20 Stunden in der Gewalt der
hamasterroristen war und in baliberann
die ein kebutz vor dem Angriff schützte
beidens Präsenz soll eine Warnung sein
an Iran und an Irans Milizen in der
Region meine Botschaft an jeden Staat
jeden feindlichen Akteur der darüber
nachdenkt Israel anzugreifen bleibt
gleich tu es nicht tu es
nicht die Strategie sagen
Ken Israel fest an sich binden um später
auch mehr Druck ausüben zu können das
Wort Feuerpause fällt nach wie vor nicht
aber es gehhe um Verhältnismäßigkeit
auch mit Blick auf Amerikas eigene
Fehler nach
9 Gerechtigkeit muss erfolgen aber ich
warne euch lasst euch von der Wut nicht
verbrennen während beidens Treffen mit
arabischen Führern abgesagt wird landet
der Bundeskanzler in
in einer Zeit in der die Glaubwürdigkeit
des Westens in der arabischen Welt auf
dem Spiel steht wird Deutschlands Rolle
als Vermittler und humanitärer Helfer in
Ägypten
geschätzt die roten Linien sind schnell
klar noch einmal wiederholt Kairo dass
es nur langfristige Lösungen geben könne
es brauche endlich einen
palästinensischen Staat anstatt nun
hunderttausende Palästinenser nach
Ägypten zu
bringen die Idee einer Migration oder
Vertreibung vom en nach Ägypten das wäre
das was bei der Vertreibung der
Palästinenser von der Westbank nach
Jordanien
passierte und dagegen würden Millionen
Ägypter auf die Straße
gehen der Bundeskanzler habe dies
verstanden sagt Präsident s das wisse er
zu schätzen wie humanitäre Hilfe nach
Gaza hineinbringen das stehe nun im
Fokus hatweg den letzten Tagen zunächst
mal die Bereitschaft zuzulassen dass
humanitäre Hilfe nach Gaza gelangt zur
Stunde ist die Grenze zu sie öffne sich
aber bei der allernächsten Gelegenheit
heißt es nun in Kairo zumindest für
Palästinenser mit ausländischen Pässen
und für
Hilfsgüter ja und dann schalten wir auch
erstmal nach nach Israel nach sterot zu
Michael beberunge Michael es scheint als
hätte beiden oder auch Scholz da doch
etwas erreicht mit den hilfs
Lieferungen zumindest sein Minimalziel
hat Joe Biden erreicht er hat von
premier netanyaho die öffentliche und
persönliche Zusicherung bekommen dass er
bei der weiteren Kriegsführung alles tun
will um weiteren Schaden von der
Zivilbevölkerung abzuwenden und eben die
Zusage dass es diesen humanitären
Korridor geben soll für Hilfslieferungen
bisher ist die Grenze zwar immer noch
geschlossen aber Ägypten hat inzwischen
klar gesagt sagt die Grenze wird
geöffnet werden allernächster Zeit
allerdings werden keine
palästinensischen Flüchtlinge aus dem
Gazastreifen hereingelassen sondern nur
die ausländischen Staatsbürger die dort
warten ein Satz der einem da heute ins
Auge springen konnte wenn man diesen
Besuch von beiden beobachtet hat war die
Warnung an die Israelis davor die Fehler
zu wiederholen die die USA nach ihrem
9-11 gemacht haben wie ordnest du das
ein ja ich fand das auch ein
beeindruckendes Eingeständnis und eine
nachdrückliche Mahnung an Netanyahu wie
es denn weitergehen soll in der Tat
denke ich wollen die USA Wissen von
ihrem Verbündeten was denn die
Kriegsziele sind was kommt denn nach
einer möglichen Bodenoffensive was kommt
nach einer möglichen Rück Rückeroberung
von Gaza nach der Zerschlagung der Hamas
Joe Biden hat gesagt es könne nicht
einfach sein dass Israel einfach dort
die Besatzung wieder übernimmt und diese
Fragen sind alle unbeantwortet und das
in einer Zeit wo Joe Biden ja quasi mit
dem Aufmarsch von zwei
flugzeugträgergruppen vor dem Libanon
Israel in gewisser Weise einen blanosck
ausgestellt hat für das
sicherheitsbündnis viele offene Fragen
gline atai ist sonst aus Kairo
zugeschaltet gline man sich das er noch
mal ansieht eigentlich sollte es ja ein
Vierer Gipfel geben ein Treffen beiden
mit dem Palästinenserpräsidenten Abbas
in Jordanien alles abgesagt kann man
jetzt sagen dass diese diplomatischen
Bemühungen erstmal tot sind oder
zumindest auf sehr schwerem
Gelände ich würde sagen zumindest auf
sehr schwerem Gelände das war heute
keine einfache Reise denn je mehr Gewalt
es gibt im gaserstreifen gegen
Zivilisten umso größer wird der Spagat
zwischen der arabischen Welt und der
westlichen Welt und diesen Spagat den
hat heute auch der Bundeskanzler
mitbekommen er hat dieses
auseinanderklaffen der Wahrnehmungen
natürlich gespürt die Entfremdung ist
besond ers groß in Richtung der USA eine
so große Entfremdung habe ich hier
gegenüber Deutschland nicht festgestellt
auch wenn man sich hier erwartungsgemäß
damit Schwert diese Idee der deutschen
staatsresung des Schutzes
Israels zu verstehen aber man hat diese
ganz eindeutige Erwartung an westliche
Staatsmänner dass hier ein eindeutiges
Ende der Kampfhandlungen ausgerufen wird
dass das gefordert wird von Israel und
dass es nicht passiert das sorgt hier
vor für Kopf tütteln und das ist auch
die Idee warum man hier einen eigenen
Friedensgipfel einberufen hat am
Wochenende mit vielen internationalen
Gästen von dem ganz klar so sagen die
Ägypter das eindeutige Signal ausgehen
soll dass eine Feuerpause ganz dringend
gebraucht wird schauen mal wie sich das
entwickelt danke schön nach Kairo und
nach sterott wenn es das Ziel der Hamas
und das Ziel Irans ist jegliche
Annährung zwischen Israel und anderen
arabischen Staaten zu sabotieren so
gelingt das bislang jedenfalls recht gut
die gestrige Explosion am Krankenhaus in
Gaza hat dann aber ja noch mehr bewirkt
als der erneute Kriegsausbruch infolge
des Terrors vom 7 Oktober nämlich eine
Art
Massenmobilisierung und nicht nur in
arabischen Ländern ob es stimmt was die
Hamas unmittelbar nach der Explosion
sagte dass die Israelis das Krankenhaus
beschossen haben und es mindestens 500
Tote gab ob das überhaupt stimmt spielt
dabei keine Rolle mehr das Öl ist im
Feuer auch in Deutschland in Berlin
wurde letzte Nacht sogar eine Synagoge
angegriffen Stefan Merseburger und
Markus groß
berichten ein paar Blumen und Kerzen als
Zeichen der Verbundenheit und Bestürzung
es sind zwei Bürger die am Nachmittag
zur angegriffenen Synagoge kommen ich
bin einfach sprachlos über die Gewalt
und den Hass gegenüber Juden jetzt
weltweit und wir müssen einfach als
Zivilgesellschaft uns jetzt wo die
Synagogen Stellen vor jüdische
Einrichtung damit es nicht zu einer
neuen reisburg romnch kommt
Spurensicherung am Morgen in Berlin
Mitte in der Nacht wurden zwei
Brandsätze auf die Kahal adas Israel
Gemeinde geworfen sie trafen das Gebäude
nicht dort sind eine Synagoge eine
Schule und eine Kita ich wohne in dieser
Gegend seit 22 Jahren jeden Tag bin ich
da und es nie sowas passiert also ich
laufe immer mit meiner kiper an ich
kenne alle Nachbarn hier sehr sicher
Nachbarschaft würde ich sagen und jetzt
plötzlich sowas natürlich un nicht
unerwartet aber
trotzdem schockierend und überraschend
der Bürgermeister kommt und ermahnt die
Bürger besonnen zu bleiben die
Stadtgesellschaft dürfe sich nicht
spalten lassen Brandanschläge auf
Synagogen sind Brandanschläge gegen uns
alle und nach den Greultaten der Nazis
bin ich dankbar und glücklich dass wir
wieder ein jüdisches Leben in unserer
stad hab aber das ist nicht nur ein
Glücksfall sondern es ist do eine
Verpflichtung eine Verpflichtung dieses
jüdische Leben in unserer Stadt zu
schützen sie bekommen jeden Tag Post
voller Hass weil sie Juden sind
Studierende aus Berlin auf jeden Fall
keine Überraschung was wir jetzt sehen
es ist etwas das sich spätestens seit
2021 angebannt hat wovor wir immer
wieder gewarnt haben wo wir immer wieder
gesagt haben jüdische Personen auf den
Straßen draußen sind nicht sicher es
gibt Menschen in deuts und viele
Menschen in Deutschland die Terror gut
heißen die islamistischen Terror gut
heißen und Judenhass gut heißen die
Situation wie wir sie jetzt gerade haben
die Stimmung und vor allem die
Verzweiflung von Jüdinnen und Juden
darüber wo sie ihre Zukunft sehen und ob
es eine Zukunft für uns ob es eine
Zukunft für uns in diesem Land gibt oder
überhaupt irgendwo eine Zukunft für uns
gibt die hat Ausmaße angenommen die wir
bisher nicht kannten
proalästinensische Demonstrationen
werden seit dem 7 Oktober verboten die
Gründe Gefahr von Ausschreitungen
Volksverhetzung und anti Semitismus die
Polizei löst die spontanen Versammlungen
immer wieder auf das frustriert deutsche
Palästinenser sie sind genauso stolz auf
ihre deutsche wie ihre palästinensische
Herkunft sie sind traurig aufgebracht
und
tröstlich und was ihren Schmerz noch
größer macht ist dass sie ihre Wut und
ihre Trauer nicht ausdrücken
dürfen
am Abend in Neuköln wieder eine
verbotene Demonstration wieder
gewaltraketen und Böller gegen die
Polizei und wieder antisemitische
paronen im heute journal Update gibt es
dAzur nachher noch ein Gespräch mit dem
Bezirksbürgermeister von Neuköln der wah
gab das Auswärtige Amt bekannt dass bei
den Terrorangriffen am 7 Oktober auch
mehrere deutsche getötet wurden nach wie
vor sind auch deutsche unter den
verschlep Geisel darüber hinaus befinden
sich deutsche Staatsbürger im
Gazastreifen Staatsbürger die dort leben
oder zu Besuch waren das Auswärtige Amt
spricht hier von einer niedrigen
dreistelligen Zahl laufend aktuelle
Informationen zu diesem gesamten
Themenkomplex finden Sie bei uns
natürlich wie immer auch online auf ZDF
heute und jetzt geht's bei dir erstmal
weiter Heinz zunächst mit dem Blick auf
die USA ja das
usreäsentantenhaus bleibt zunächst
weiter ohne regulären Vorsitzenden damit
ist diese Parlamentskammer in weiten
Teilen ihrer Arbeit blockiert und
aktuell nicht in der Lage auf die
Situation in Nahost und in der Ukraine
zu reagieren der republikanische
Abgeordnete Jim Jordan hat auch heute in
einem zweiten Wahlgang keine
ausreichende Mehrheit bekommen es
stimmten erneut mehrere Abgeordnete aus
seiner eigenen Fraktion gegen Jordan der
als Verbündeter von Ex-Präsident Trump
gilt der Bundestag hat über eine
teilweise Legalisierung von Cannabis
beraten es ging zum ersten Mal um den
Gesetzentwurf der Regierung sie
begründet das Vorhaben damit dass der
Konsum trotz der bisherigen
Verbotsregelung ansteige man den
illegalen Markt eindämmen und
Konsumenten besser etwa vor giftigen
Beimengungen bei schwarzmarktprodukten
schützen wolle während
Gesundheitsminister Lauterbach das
Vorhaben verteidigte kritisierte die
Union der Gesetzentwurf sei mit dem
Jugend Schutz unvereinbar und
vernachlässige die gesundheitlichen
Risiken die Linken Politikerin Sara
wagenkncht wird nach übereinstimmenden
Medienberichten am Montag die Gründung
eines Vereins BSW für Vernunft und
Gerechtigkeit öffentlich vorstellen
dieser Schritt gilt als eine Art
Vorstufe zur Gründung einer eigenen
Partei das Kürzel BSW stehe für Bündnis
Sarah Wagenknecht heißt es dies hätten
mehrere Quellen aus ihrem Umfeld
bestätigt auf auf Nachfrage wollte
wagenknechtsbüro die Berichte weder
bestätigen noch
kommentieren das bis zum achenen hat im
Rahmen der Aufarbeitung sexualisierter
Gewalt Namen mutmaßlicher Täter
veröffentlicht die bereits verstorben
sind auf der Liste stehen 53
Beschuldigte darunter auch der früher
weibibischof August Peters mit dem
vorgehen sollen bislang unbekannte
Betroffene ermutigt werden sich zu
melden die systematische Nennung der
Namen ist laut Missbrauchsbeauftragten
der Deutschen Bischofskonferenz bislang
bundesweit
einmalig russland will sich offenbar aus
einem weiteren internationalen
sicherheitsvertrag zurückziehen dem
Abkommen zum Verbot von Atomwaffentests
für einen entsprechenden Gesetzentwurf
stimmte die Duma das russische Unterhaus
mit 415 zu0 Stimmen Präsident Putin
hatte das Parlament dazu aufgefordert
mit der Begründung die USA hätten den
Vertrag 1996 zwar unterzeichn aber nie
ratifiziert wladimir Putin hat übrigens
zu den Vorgängen in Nahost bislang
relativ wenig gesagt die Explosion in
Gaza bezeichnete er allerdings als
Katastrophe und Tragödie die
Glaubwürdigkeit dieser empathiebezeugung
leidet ein wenig darunter dass Russland
in der jüngeren Vergangenheit zahlreiche
Krankenhäuser bombardiert hat in der
Ukraine und in Syrien letzteres übrigens
ohne dass das Massenproteste in der
arabischen Welt ausgelöst hätte auch der
sogenannte globale Süden stört sich an
den aktuellen Verbrechen des russischen
Regimes nicht wirklich in Peking gab es
heute jedenfalls einen herzlichen
Empfang und viele die sehr gern
russische Hände schüttelten
Beobachtungen dazu von Anselm
Stern in Peking wird Russlands
kremmelherrscher an die Hand genommen
Freunde beim Fototermin Wladimir Putin
und shijinping sprechen heute von tiefer
Freundschaft von gemeinsamen
außenpolitischen zielen sie sprechen in
ihren offiziellen gipfelreden aber nicht
über das Sterben über das Grauen in
Israel und in der Ukraine
ideologische Konfrontation geopolitische
Rivalität und blockpolitik sind für uns
keine Option wir stellen uns gegen
einseitige Sanktionen und gegen
wirtschaftlichen
Zwang Russland und China teilen den
Wunsch nach gleichberechtigter
Zusammenarbeit bei der die Vielfalt und
die Rechte jedes Staates sich zu
entwickeln respektiert
werden sagt der Kriegsherr sein brutaler
Überfall auf die Ukraine wird auch
finanziert durch viele chinesische
Milliarden für Russlands Rohstoffe
Peking und Moskau intensivieren die
wirtschaftspolitischen Signale gegen den
Westen und ihre
Wirtschaftsbeziehungen das
Handelsvolumen der be Länder haben einen
historischen Höchststand erreicht es
liege in diesem Jahr bei ca 190
Milliarden
Euro wir haben drei Stunden gesprochen
es gibt eine bilaterale Agenda bei
vielen Themen Wirtschaft Finanzen und
Politik die Partnerschaft zwischen China
und Russland ist in den letzten Jahren
zunehmend enger geworden nicht nur
politisch sondern auch als
Handelspartner sind sich näher gekommen
die Abhängigkeit Russlands von China ist
dabei deutlich größer für Russland ist
China der wichtigste Handelspartner
China profitiert vor allen von den
günstigen Energielieferungen aus
Russland so ist russlands Präsident in
Peking ein sehr willkommener Gast das
Tandem Putin Chi führte gemeinsam viele
andere Staatenlenker zum
seidenstraßengipfeldinner gekommen waren
vor allem Vertreter aus Afrika Asien
Südamerika eine Delegation der Taliban
und als einziger
eu-regierungschef Viktor Orban aus
Ungarn der wichtigste Gast aber war
Vladimir Putin der sich hier übrigens
keine Sorgen machen muss wegen seines
laufenden Haftbefehls China erkennt den
Internationalen Strafgerichtshof in Den
Hag nicht
an und jetzt noch mal Heins mit anderen
Themen dieses Tages
Bundesarbeitsminister Heil will
hunderttausende geflüchtete mit
Bleibeperspektive schneller in Arbeit
bringen er spricht von einem Job Turbo
weil Haller was heißt das konkret Heil
geht es dabei schwerpunktmäßig um
ukrainische geflüchtete rund 200.000
könnten in Deutschland arbeiten die
meisten aber beziehen noch Bürgergeld
ähnliches gilt für 200.000 weitere
anerkannte Asylbewerber sie sollen nun
möglichst schnell Arbeit bekommen im
Kern sollen geflüchtete intensiver als
bisher betreut werden dreh und
Angelpunkt sind die Jobcenter die sich
künftig mit Nachdruck um diese Gruppe
kümmern sollen indem sie berufliche
Fähigkeiten und Qualifizierungsbedarf
ermitteln in regelmäßigen Terminen
prüfen wie es vorangeht und wer nicht
kooperiert muss mit Sanktionen rechnen
wie einer Kürzung des Bürgergeldes
Arbeitsminister Heil wünscht sich auch
eine Beteiligung der Wirtschaft und
Sozialpartner Betriebe sollen motiviert
werden geflüchtete auch mit nicht so
guten Deutschkenntnissen einzustellen
die konzertierte Aktion der
Bundesregierung rührt auch daher dass
andere Länder mit der Integration von
ukrainischen geflüchteten in den
Arbeitsmarkt wesentlich schneller
vorankommen in den Niederlanden
beispielsweise liegt die Erwerbsquote
einer Untersuchung zufolge bei 70% in
Deutschland nur bei rund 20%. wer Haller
vielen Dank und jetzt die Zahlen vom
lotor Mittwoch sie lauten wie immer ohne
Gewehr 15 16 31 42 45 47 und die
Superzahl 2 weitere Gewinnzahlen finden
sie auf
lotto.zdfde und im ZDF Text auf Seite
557 zwei Ergebnisse aus der Fußball
Champions League der Frauen heute Abend
war Eintracht Frankfurt zu Gast bei
Sparta Prag und konnte sich mit einem
3:0 erstmals für die Gruppenphase
qualifizieren und erstmals seit 2012
nicht dabei der fufel Wolfsburg nach dem
unentschiedenem Hinspiel heute zu Hause
gegen Paris FC nur ein
0:2 bei den Männern kehrt die deutsche
Fußballnationalmannschaft mit einem Sieg
und einem Unentschieden von ihrer USA
Reise zurück nachdem 3:1 gegen Gastgeber
USA gab es gegen Mexiko ein
2:2 es war ein hart umkämpftes 22 das
den Positivtrend bestätigte jedoch auch
Mängel in der Verteidigung zeigte
losgelöst von den defensivproblemen ist
es auf der USA Reise gelungen
Einstellung Stimmung und Offensive zu
verbessern werden erfolgreich sein da
bin ich absolut überzeugt weil wir uns
sehr schnell aneinander gewöhnt haben
und sehr schnell auch Schritte gemacht
haben die Jungs haben sehr schnell Dinge
umgesetzt schnell als ich das sonst in
den Clubs gewöhnt war nach der 1:
Führung durch Abwehrchef Rüdiger bekommt
die wacklige Defensive zunehmend
Probleme die antuna ausnutzt der
Ausgleich weil süle und Rüdiger zu
nachlässig und fehlerhaft agieren auch
beim 21 durch sanes zeigt sich das
dfbteam nur abwehrbereit goens darf die
Flanke nicht zulassen und dann ist beim
einrücken erneut Rechtsverteidiger süle
unaufmerksam die defensiven Außenbahnen
bleiben die problemempositionen im
nagelsmannteam das dann noch das 22
erzielt fkrug bewahrt die deutsche
Auswahl mit seinem neunten Tor im El
Spiel vor einer möglichen Niederlage ist
auch irgendwo normal glaube ich dass man
Schwankung hat gerade wenn es dann auch
am Anfang ist in den Leistungen es ist
Lernprozess an der Stabilität in der
Defensive muss weiter gearbeitet
werden das war's von uns mit dem
auslandsjournal geht es gleich weiter
natürlich auch mit Berichten aus narost
um 040 Uhr meldet sich dann grunduler
Gause mit unserem heute schnal Update
und wir sind morgen wieder da auf
Wiedersehen
[Musik]
wiedersehen
schön guten Abend und herzlich
willkommen zum Wetter über dem
westlichen Europa bildet sich ein
umfangreiches tiefsystem aus sie sehen
ist hier mehrere tiefsind dabei und
dieser Schnelläufer der bringt sogar
Richtung Mittelmeer kräftigen Regen und
viel Wind mit sehr ungemütlich geht es
in den nächsten Tagen weiter schauen wir
in die kommende Nacht und da gibt's
Regen bis zur Elbe ansonsten nach Norden
erst einmal trocken und auch im Südosten
Temperaturen gehen zurück auf 4° in den
östlichen Landesteilen und 12° ganz im
Westen am Vormittag morgen dann viel
Regen in den östlichen Landesteilen und
auch Richtung Küsten ja und im Süden da
scheint etwas die Sonne aber im
Südwesten kommt neue Bewölkung auf und
spitzens zum Nachmittag müssen wir dort
mit Schauern und auch mit Gewittern
rechnen ganz im Norden regnet es weiter
dazu gibt's einen kräftigen östlichen
Wind ja zwischendurch aber auch mal
etwas Sonnenschein bei höchsten
Temperaturen bis 8° in den östlichen
Landesteilen und 21° im Süden
Deutschlands die nächsten Tage sehr
ungemütlich teils mit orkanböhne am
Freitag im Nord Deutschlands dazu
Schauer in der Mitte kräftiger Regen bei
6 bis 22° und auch das Wochenende
gestaltet sich sehr wechselhaft mit
weiteren Schauern aber immer noch
relativ mild und damit einen schönen
Abend